oh there is uh a video that went viral
on tick tock it's kind of a new thing
that i've been seeing where
people who work at gas stations or
liquor stores will record them having
interactions with their like regulars
and this guy
started to record a homeless man who
would come in and try to buy
like food cigarettes and stuff uh a lot
of his fans
ended up falling in love with this guy
because he just seemed like he had a
really positive attitude down on his
luck
and this is the video that went viral go
all the way down
all the way down
keep going this one yeah
so like tick would uh set up cash apps
and they'd
uh fans would send money to give to this
homeless man so he'd give him like 100
200 based off of donations just help him
get an id
a used phone so he kind of get his life
back on track
and this is him saying that he needed i
believe two hundred dollars to get
a pair of glasses from walmart because
he couldn't see
and so he's being given five hundred
dollars and he starts crying it's just a
feel-good video
what are you trying to get some glasses
yeah that's what i'm doing i can't see
but thanks for you you
it wasn't for you man i love you a lot
don't you get me on the right track
i have a little bit of money everybody
started yeah i'm ready
yes how much how much you make today
eleven dollars
you made eleven dollars seven dollars i
bought a bunch of food i
i yes i'm starting bus because
so how much your glasses cost about 150
at walmart 150 dollars
for you go get a room go get yourself i
am tomorrow
i'm gonna get my glasses i'm gonna be a
[ __ ] moment
[Music]
oh my god and that was viewed
on the original account i think 13.
[Laughter]
what do we think that he's using that
500
for all that stuff do we not think he's
going to turn that 500 some drug money
no i think he's going to get glasses
i think i i think 150 that will go to
classes
what happens the other money that's
that's where i get dicey with
homeless people well you can't give them
too much yeah
two days ago also you can catch a vibe
yeah you can kind of figure it out yeah
you can see someone that's just
genuinely yeah he seems pretty
genuine yeah money changed people
well remember 150 that's going to hit so
he can glasses and
what happened to the other that's what
i'm that's where i get dicey with it
like if he has a drug problem you're
just enabling him
yeah yeah you have 350 dollars he's
gonna look like he cracked down right no
no no i'm
like when you see a lot of those dudes
on the side of the road who have the
signs you're like uh
i give you money you're just gonna it's
just gonna enable your drug habit
sometimes yeah you can really tell yeah
that one i can't i need to see more
videos how do you guys feel
about um this is just my personal
opinion but how do you guys feel about
people
filming themselves doing good deeds like
that it turns out well
right because people want to contribute
but i always feel like that's weird like
i mean i think it's everyone's
whatever you want to do like i'd say
don't film it yeah just do it
just do it but then i guess he got in
recognition so but also at the same time
when you look at like
everything that is like put out on the
news you never really see stuff like
this that's
so nice so like that's i mean what's
like you do you know what uh barstool is
doing
have you ever watched it yeah yeah we
talked about on king the sting and
we actually donated to it five thousand
dollars yeah barstool they're trying to
save small businesses
so they've raised like 12 million
dollars i think it's 17 or 18 million is
it up to 18 million now
so they have all these businesses send
in that they need help they have to
prove that they were successful before
everything and then they save them for a
few months that's what i'm saying
because you're saving the small business
no no because the government's not
doing it so the people have to come up
with creative ideas to [ __ ] get it
done but i used to i used to be like you
chin i
i used to think it was like weird to
like film but but that but like now it's
like
you know what no it's it's not bad i
mean people need to see
some type of light because there's so
much that's just thrown out there man
you changed my you're changing mine
right now you're just changing mine oh
yo you
you were i i thought it was just like
look at me look what i'm doing
yeah attention but then at the end of
the day it used to be just like that i'm
like man
why are you yeah you know but it's it's
there's just so much craziness in the
world
that's a good point you got to see some
some good my friend
donated 20 000 to like different
families on happy on he
never like shows it but i just feel like
a lot he was getting a lot of flack on
like why he didn't speak up and stuff
like that he normally just like
donates and don't give and give and give
but then he felt like i'm a document and
show y'all what i do he does this all
the time he gave 20
000 away to different family wow which
is where like you don't have to don't
have to die
if you just do it just you know just you
know that happened a lot with recent
celebrities where
uh with all of these kind of like issues
with
i think it was black lives matter a lot
of people came out against beyonce about
not speaking up and stuff like that and
with politics like
people go after celebrities for not
saying as if like they owe
the public an explanation for what they
do behind them he was like bro this is
what i do i'ma show you instead of
saying
something i'm gonna show you my actions
and this i'm helping families yeah
just like and again he didn't want to do
it because he's a private guy but the
fact that people was like
you know social media you say it all the
time is not real he's like this is what
i'm doing in real life what are you all
doing with yourself yeah exactly instead
of typing you see what i'm saying even
then it's weird for him to post i think
what do you mean like who gives a like
if you're moving like that you don't i
don't think i've ever posted that stuff
i do yeah not for christmas or
[ __ ] a lot of things i never post either
but i'm just saying people
i think that people like want to show
you like yo i'm a g like it's a lot of
genuine people in the world right
but why do you feel you need to validate
it to like instagram but
to instagram well because i think that
the notion why would you give a flying
[ __ ] if someone's like oh he did donate
that money all right dude
cool man i mean like another what do you
what are you saying yeah well how he
he was saying he moved does a bunch of
stuff like this help people out though i
was like this is how i do it
yeah you know what i'm saying like y'all
don't think this is like who gives a
[ __ ]
yeah yeah you know i don't know if you
like if you want to show it show it if
you don't
you don't have to that's how i feel i
just think that people like
too many like everyone has their own
opinions and you're entitled to that but
the fact that
like you just can't judge someone off
like something like i don't want to say
anything but i'm doing stuff behind the
scenes i even be honest
you don't have to say anything yeah
exactly but if you want to document it
ain't nothing wrong with it yeah
but some people like the movement it's
like kevin hart was talking about it how
when the [ __ ] happened with nick cannon
they're like oh you're not going to
support him not give it back he's like
you [ __ ] idiot he was at my house
yesterday thank you
how do you think he came but with the
moves he did who do you think made the
connections
who do you think called fox he's with me
right now
he's like he's like i don't have to post
all this [ __ ] yeah you know but dude
but you see how he had to like like i
don't i wouldn't say cave to the
social media but you see how he had to
respond like bro kevin hart
he always responds yeah he entertains
that yeah he always responds even the
the the criticism
what do you mean oh yeah where he had to
step down yeah before for an old
queen like that he already asked him
back
and he's like no i'm good mm-hmm yeah
well look at this special he had his
baby uh in a little baby suit that said
no [ __ ] giving
for his special people came [ __ ] people
gave him [ __ ] he was like again oh my
god like i don't feel like so you just
have to address it but is it
is it everybody giving them [ __ ] or it's
just it's just a small percentage
yeah but there's such a like there's
this clip that netflix posted
like i think it was uh it was bill burr
uh on david spade's new show
and fortunately fema star was like um
you made a white woman mad at you
because of your snl monologue yeah but
he was like
he's like no they only interviewed the
ones that were mad he goes not everybody
was [ __ ] mad about it no the monster
is small it's such a small percentage of
people so like
is everybody upset about it no i don't
think it's
everybody it's just a [ __ ] small
percentage we just make it and you don't
want it
and you don't want to answer give that
any energy yeah yeah you're answering to
a small percentage of people
you know what i mean for most people
when you post like yeah it gives a [ __ ]
yeah most of the time i scroll past the
[ __ ] i just think that
like we are as humans we are i want to
say we feel
positive positive things we're natural
it feels natural but something negative
you just like want to give that
attention because like
it's unnatural right everyone do you
understand what i'm saying yeah
batteries he literally doesn't have to
answer those [ __ ] but
exactly he doesn't have to be because
they don't change anything they don't
change anything he does no
no exactly all right did the grammys ask
him back they sure as [ __ ]
hell did yeah is he still kevin hart
yeah he'll say kevin
yeah exactly just drop a new special on
netflix yeah exactly so you're saying
you're basically saying you don't have
to cater people [ __ ] talking
i would never answer you two teflon
people [ __ ] talking doesn't outweigh
someone's talent of course you know what
i mean if the talent is there
talented it's like the same people get
on like oh kevin's not funny all right
cool man
all right millions and millions of
people disagree thank you
and they're not giving comments correct
they're showing up the shows they're
building
their shows they're buying the shows
that speaks louder than the [ __ ] talking
you don't have to entertain now if kevin
said something and then
he wasn't selling tickets he's not
selling merch or whatever then you
you'd be different okay then you got a
problem okay so you see you're basically
saying he
he has too much time addressing i'm
saying don't cater to the
minority okay all right well yeah
basically you came in well that's what i
guess celebrities i just feel like you
you get so much heat because again you
want to be
loved at the end of the day your junior
guy you want to be lucky but i get what
you're saying but listen they want to
address it like beyonce
she want to address she addressed it
like here money this is what i do
my friend this is what i do so kevin
hart this is what i do so it's just
i just think that people they can do
whatever they want yeah
they're still human also at the same
time not everyone's gonna [ __ ] like
you
exactly but in that day they still human
which is which is [ __ ] fine
yeah you know if you're still able to do
what the [ __ ] you're able to do yeah i
don't think you know what have you
liked what did you say i don't think
anybody's universally like
that's horrible that'd be weird
what else you got jen how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son